salut réveillez vous il ya du nouveau du
côté des rêves lucides je vous ai déjà
fait des vidéos sur ce sujet fascinant
il ya deux ou trois ans je vous mets
d'ailleurs ces vidéos là dans la
description pour vous remettre dans le
contexte j'ai une fascination pour le
sommeil les rêves lucides et l'étude du
sommeil ce qui m'a amené ya quelques
années à faire des stages en os lire au
logis l'oni rôle au jc l'étude du rêve
je vous avais fait également une vidéo
sur comment se souvenir de ses rêves qui
améliorent la fréquence de ses rêves
lucides et une vidéo en jo-2018 sur les
nouvelles façons de dormir et
d'appréhender semaine nous allons
rentrer dans le vif du sujet puisque ya
du nouveau à dire mais avant je vous
rappelle que c'est la fin de la saison
de ma tournée il reste plus que 3 bill
pas il reste aussi la suisse mais c'est
complet depuis très longtemps j'ai
rajouté une date à royan charente
maritime c'est le 5 juillet donc si vous
êtes de la rochelle de royan de
rochefort tout ça évidemment vous étiez
bienvenus ça fait je suis pas venu
depuis 2015 et une date aussi le 26
juillet à lunel dans le sud et trois
dates au québec
oui j'ai bien dit au québec je joue au
québec le 15 16 et 17 août dans la ville
de québec pour le festival comedia vous
avez un lien dans la description vers
tout ce qui concerne mon site la main en
spectacle au québec c'est une petite
salle de 100 places reste un très très
intime donc réservé vaut mieux en fait
aujourd'hui je vous propose une mise à
jour des deux dernières années
concernant le rêve le sommeil et les
rêves lucides le rêve lucide sait faire
un rêve tout en ayant conscience que
l'on est en train de rêver et là il ya
deux possibilités à ce moment là soit on
est omnipotent c'est à dire qu'on peut
gérer tout le décorum tout ce qui s'y
passe les des interventions des
personnes appelées pouvoir qu'on a ou
alors on peut avoir conscience que l'on
rêve mais on subit le scénario et le
décor et on peut juste décidé de secours
fait à l'intérieur de ce raid on laisse
notre inconscient nous proposer ce qu'il
a envie de vous proposer la dernière
vidéo que j'avais faite sur le sommeil
en juin 2018 est en partenariat avec
dream et leur hallucinant bandeau qu'ils
avaient créée pour le sommeil car
justement pour faire des rêves lucides
il faut commencer par avoir un bon
sommeil et dream vient de sortir leur
nouveau bandeau là
nouvelles versions de leurs bandeaux de
rim pour pour la nuit ils ont eu la
sympathie de me l'envoyer pour que je
puisse le tester et vous fermez retour
et vous dire ce que j'en pense et il n'y
a pas mal de choses à dire sur le sujet
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé ces deux
dernières années concernant les rêves
lucides et le sommeil loïc générique nom
générique de la vidéo loïc même si c'est
clair en général on fait toujours un
générique de la vidéo loïc
[Musique]
chaque personne fort moyenne cent mille
rêves
au cours de sa vie avec une moyenne de 5
rêve au cours de chaque nuit et là je
sais je vous entends déjà faire tac tac
tac tac dans les commentaires il y en a
plein qui disent qu'ils ne rêve jamais
ces faux dont vous rêvez mais juste vous
ne vous souvenez pas de vos rêves mais
je vous rassure vraiment tout le monde
arabe et même les personnes qui se
souviennent de leurs rêves ne se
souviennent pas en réalité de tous les
rêves qu'ils ont faits au cours de leur
nuit si vous vous souvenez vraiment pas
des rêves que vous faites durant la nuit
je vous renvoie vers cette vidéo que
j'avais fait qui vous apprend à faire ça
et à optimiser en fait le rappel et le
souvenir de vos rêves
au final il ya quand même 40 2 % des
personnes qui se souviennent d'au moins
un de leurs rêves de chaque matin il ya
34 % la population qui se souvient au
moins d'un de leurs rêves de la semaine
sont plutôt des bons scores nos rêves
sont toujours composés d'un combat de
quelque chose à résoudre d'une quête il
ya toujours en fait un scénario avec une
dramaturgie un petit peu comme dans un
vrai film 38 % de nos rêves comporte des
éléments qui sont liées à notre passé ça
peut être une semaine une journée un an
en arrière mais des choses de l'ordre du
souss guy roux des choses qu'on n'a pas
réglé ou des choses qui nous tracasse ou
des choses dont on a eu un rappel
dernièrement 32% nos rêves comporte des
éléments concernant notre futur alors
c'est pas des flashs de voyants on
devine pas le futur mais pas lyon vous
savez que vous avez un examen à passer
une vous en rêvez un petit peu à
l'avance en bien ou en mal
et puis tout le reste en fait comporte
des éléments qui n'ont rien à voir avec
la réalité dans laquelle on vit je parle
pas de choses surnaturelles ou d'alien
août choses comme ça mais juste des
événements ou des éléments qui n'ont
rien à voir avec notre passé où les
éléments qui nous attend dans notre
futur la première grande avancée qu'on
ait pu faire ces dernières années c'est
que à partir de maintenant on sait
exactement où se situent les rêves dans
notre cerveau c'était pas le cas avant
et c'est grâce à une neurologue qui
s'appelle francesca cycle aride du ch uv
de lausanne à la mesure est calculé sa
halle a réussi à publier une étude sur
le sujet et donc tous les rêves sont
situés à complètement à l'arrière du
cerveau alors y'a pas une seule zone ça
fait intervenir pas mal de zones mais ça
on y reviendra
et tout se trouve vraiment tous derrière
le cerveau jusqu'à aujourd'hui on
n'avait que des hypothèses parce que le
problème c'est que même les ce qu'on
appelle les bons rêveur
ne se souviennent pas de tous leurs
rêves on les évacue très vite et c'est
normal on était programmé pour ça pour
faire la différence entre la réalité et
le rêve un jour je vous avais donné cet
exemple mais il est très précis imaginez
qu'il ya un chien qui est en train de
rêver qu'il est en train de pourchasser
je sais pas moi un lapin dans un champ
auquel est en train de courir derrière
imaginer que si au moment où il se
réveillait le chien il se souvient
encore de ce rêve il soit encore un peu
dans ce rêve là pour lui ce sera encore
la réalité ils chercheraient ou et
l'animal dans la maison ils feraient pas
la différence
pannoux à la base nous sommes des
animaux et on a eu le même la même
sauvegarde on va dire le fait de
d'évacuer suite le rêve au réveil pour
reprendre contact avec le monde réel
oui ca est ce que c'est un rêve où tu es
à côté d'une caméra et que tu fais le
point sur mon visage et écoute si le son
on tourne bien ah oui oui et quand tu
travailles tu le cherche encore oui
c'est vrai ce constat l'a été quantifié
par le docteur antonio arda de
l'institut des rêves de montréal c'est
donc en captant l'activité neuronale des
rêveurs qu'on a pu faire avancer la
science de ce côté là les 32
participants et volontaire à l'étude de
francesca avait 256 électrodes chacun
demi sur leurs crânes et donc elle a
étudié cette activité neuronale dont je
vous parlais et à la pu prédire
l'arrivée des rêves dans 92% des cas
92% des cas elle était capable d hier
attention il va arriver à partir de
maintenant et il était en train de rêver
comment elle a su qu'il était en train
de rêver et bien en fait tout simplement
il réveillé les patients ou les
volontaires on va plutôt les appeler
comme ça il est réveillé en moyenne
d'ailleurs cette fois par nuit pour
vérifier qu'au moment où il pensait
qu'ils étaient en train de rêver est ce
que oui éviter de commencer à rêves et
en l'occurrence oui il avait un petit
peu plus loin dans la précision si par
exemple elle captait que c'est la partie
du cerveau qui gère les dialogues qui
étaient en activité que la veille et la
personne qu'elle lui demander s'il est
en train de rêver à lui demander de
raconter son rêve pour vérifier s'il
était en discussion avec quelqu'un dans
son rêve et si tout ça ça colle et
effectivement ça collait et puis aussi
le fait que le lobe préfrontal n'était
pas en activité lui était en repos
complet sachant que c'est lui qui gère
l'expérience de la conscience mais ce
qu'il faut quand même c'est que hormis
le lobe préfrontal tout le reste de
l'activité cérébrale
n'a que peu de différences entre le
sommeil et la réalité c'est assez les
mêmes zones qui s'activent pour faire le
même action que ce soit en rêve
ou quand le fait dans leurs ailes de la
partie par exemple qui gère la
reconnaissance faciale dans le réel
c'est à dire je vois quelqu'un et je
suis en train de le reconnaître une
partie du cerveau qui gère ça elle
marche de la même manière dans les rêves
que dans la réalité il ya il n'y a pas
de différence quand je reconnais
quelqu'un dans le monde réel où quand je
crois reconnaître quelqu'un dans un rêve
c'est vraiment un délire
ouais c'est un délire loïc moi aussi et
on est copains en constatant tout ça ça
a permis de et tenez vous bien quand
même parce que ça envoie du bois à cette
neurologue de commencer à essayer de
décoder des images qui serait dans le
cerveau donc par le rêve ou par la
perception pur en étudiant l'activité
cérébrale
alors oui ça envoie du lourd mais on est
quand même au balbutiement de tout ça
mais vous allez voir de se dire que
juste là on a joué à peine commencé à
travailler là dessus et on a un début on
va dire de qualité comme ça juste en
fait en captant les zones qui sont
activés dans le cerveau et l'intensité
des signaux qui sont reçus tu dis dans
un an deux ans dix ans vingt ans
peut-être on pourra voir les rêves sous
forme de film parce que là
l'intelligence artificielle quand même
ressort des photos qui sont plutôt
ressemblante
là par exemple une personne voyez une
image et dans son cerveau il s'est passé
ça et l'intelligence artificielle a
montré sa en photo à l'adie pour moi
l'image qu'il a dans sa tête c'est ça
alors là oui effectivement ça ressemble
à rien en fait c'était cet avion là
qu'il imaginait qui venait de regarder
et l'atelier a ouais c'est pas mal c'est
également le cas pour cette chouette
c'est également le cas pour cette lettre
c est à chaque fois on se dit ok on se
rappelle qu'on est aux balbutiements au
tout début de sa et on en est déjà là
moi je crois vraiment qu'on va pouvoir
maintenant décodées des choses très
précises dans le temps c'est même un peu
flippant flippant mais bon les résultats
sont vraiment prometteur si non sip
t'as pas toujours ton matériel avec toi
si non mais des fois il ya des bugs en
parallèle de ces travaux-là l'énorme
avancé a eu lieu également la dernière
année concernant les rêves lucides
une pilule une simple pilule qui
permettrait de faire des rêves lucides
avant de vous parler de tout ça et vous
allez voir c'est juste dingue je vais
vous faire mes retours concernant le
nouveau bandeau dream donc qui m'ont
envoyé et que j'ai pu tester comme le
précédent il se porte comme ça et après
on recule un petit peu pour que ça
tienne bien ça tient d'autant plus que
maintenant il ya trois tailles
il ya s m et l avant c'était une taille
unique est la vraie première différence
c'est le confort il est beaucoup plus
souple que l'ancien et du coup c'est
très agréable et très très léger à
porter la première raison pour laquelle
il a été créé c'est pour mieux dormir
parce que si vous voulez faire des rêves
lucides il faut avoir un bon sommeil si
possible bien dormir le principe du
bandeau est toujours basé sur les mêmes
études scientifiques concernant le bruit
rose
si vous ne savez pas ce qu'est le bruit
rose je vais pas vous refaire tout
l'article vous regardez cette vidéo il
ya tout dedans et un des points
améliorable du précédent c'était la
diffusion du son surtout sur la partie
méditation ou la partie endormissement
alors pas pour l'écouter jamais eu de
problème à l'écouté par contre la
personne à côté
parfois elle pouvait l'entendre donc ils
ont considérablement amélioré la
conduction la diffusion du moins du son
par conduction osseuse vous est-ce que
c'est par les vibrations et ça passe par
les eaux et c'est comme ça après qu'on
récupère le sens qui fait que la
personne juste à côté de nous maintenant
on entend rien du tout un autre point
qu'ils ont considérablement amélioré
vous demande avait fait beaucoup par et
c'est normal c'est le prix le premier
bandeau quitté 499 euros ils ont entendu
tous les retours à ce sujet là ils l'ont
descendu maintenant à 399 euros
alors ça reste une somme considérable
c'est clair en même temps c'est pas un
gadget c'est pas un jouet c'est pas un
petit truc pour tester c'est quelque
chose qui est fait main dans la main
avec des chercheurs avec des
scientifiques c'est là la vraie symbiose
la vraie rencontre en fait entre la
théorie et la pratique la recherche et
la pratique c'est à ce jour sûrement la
meilleure méthode pour guérir de
l'insomnie ils ont accompagné beaucoup
de personnes depuis un an tous les
programmes du bandeau sont faits
par rapport à la tcc la thérapie
cognitive comportementale qui est
référencée entre autres par le ms comme
comme avant comme avec le premier
bandeau vous avez un dream coach dans
l'application vous êtes vraiment
accompagner quotidiennement dans un
suivi personnalisé par rapport à vous
donner pour avoir des astuces et des
conseils pour améliorer votre sommeil à
vous selon vos objectifs à vous par
contre je me retrouve avec deux bandeaux
l'ancien dont je me sers encore et celui
ci dont je me suis servi quinze jours
pour pouvoir le tester
donc je vais vous faire gagner celui ci
le nouveau parce que je suis pas comme
ça je vais pas vous faire gagner ça lui
je me sers déjà depuis un an je vous le
fais gagner sur mon instagram alors pour
ça vous avez forcément un lien autour de
moi parce que loïc fait un travail
remarquable
tu as vu ce qu'il a dans cette boule la
regarde mais y'a mon instagram c1
soignable bravo logique non loïc on a eu
10 - instagram pas le tien merci louis
il a envie de tester la t bien stylé là
j'ai l'impression que tel cérébraux la
voilà donc si les gens qui vont gagner
il peut ils peuvent être rassurés
six mois ça bouge au salon sera aussi
oui c'est vrai ça leur reer à salomé
thierry directement le bandeau toutes
les infos dans la description merci
beaucoup a dream de me l'avoir envoyée
maintenant que vous connaissez toutes
les possibilités pour dormir de la
meilleure manière possible
revenons à cette grande découverte la
pilule à rêves lucides
vraiment on dirait un truc fake quand je
dis ça comme ça mais ils ont vraiment
inventé ça faut commencer par comprendre
que le rêve lucide possède sa propre
signature cérébrale elle est différente
de celle du sommeil et elle est
différente de celle du rêve donc on peut
le reconnaître quand est ce qu'on est en
train de faire un rêve lucide en tout
cas quelqu'un d'extérieur s'ils me
posent aussi des électrodes peut le voir
le docteur denholm à speed définit le
rêve lucide comme étant un état modifié
de conscience a meta hybride le lobe
frontal qui gère la conscience complexe
et on va dire pour synthétiser et 1
quand on est en plein sommeil mais
durant un rêve lucide il se met
légèrement en marche les chercheurs de
l'institut de lucidité se sont aperçus
que la prise de galantamine augmenter
considérablement nos chances de faire un
rêve lucide qui mais quand je lis
considérablement
c'est à ça les augmente pas
3t beaucoup 3 oui et alors en plus si tu
as l'habitude d'utiliser des techniques
pour faire des rêves lucides tu passes à
une chance sur deux de faire un rêve
lucide quand a décidé d'en faire quand a
décidé d'en faire un et tout mettre en
place s'en fait pas forcément si tu
prends cette molécule là t'as une chance
sur deux d'enfer c'est énorme c'est
juste vous faudrait que tu prennes de la
drôle amis
[Musique]
ce que je finis tout petits hectares et
récits l'image et la presse des
tout-petits cool pour répondre à ta
question parce que c'est pas idiot loïc
n'est pas idiot bien au contraire la
galantamine à la base c'est un produit
dont on se sert pour le traitement
contre alzheimer et ils se sont aperçus
je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai lu tous à
ce sujet il n'ya pas le comment ça se
fait qu'ils ont testé ça est-ce qu'ils
ont étudiés quelqu'un qui avait un
traitement contre alzheimer ou je ne
sais pas je pas trouver la source de
pourquoi mais souvent la science al
avance à tâtons et a fait des
découvertes qui sont pas voulu il ya un
mot pour ça qui me revient pas mais ça
arrive et donc la lys ils sont aperçus
que si tu prenais 8 mg de garant tamines
au milieu de la nuit
car tu te réveilles tu mets à rêver pour
prendre de la drogue à maintes amine
wimille g et te rendormir
alors tu avais d'énormes chances de
faire un rêve lucide
attention en faisant le montage de cette
vidéo je me suis aperçu de quelque chose
d'important
quand on écoute cette vidéo on peut
avoir l'impression que je trouve ça bien
qu'on est à lier la chimie avec la
science du rêve déjà d'une manière
générale je trouve que de vouloir
traiter les problèmes du sommeil avec
des solutions médicamenteuses n'est pas
une bonne solution
il ya énormément de méthodes de
relaxation de méditation ou des méthodes
alternatives comme dream justement qui
permettent de se passer de la chimie
dans le cerveau qui dérègle des choses
ça ne se soigne pas ça couvre des
problèmes et on sait pas forcément les
dégâts que ça cause dans le cas de la
garante amine c'est encore pire je veux
dire on s'est aperçu qu'en prenant ce
médicament on pouvait faire ça mais on
n'a aucun recul et aucune donnée sur ce
qui pourrait arriver dans le long terme
je rajoute ça parce que j'ai déjà trouvé
des sites qui vendent de la galantamine
exprès pour faire des rêves lucides je
voulais des conseils et d'une manière
générale je vous déconseille tout ce qui
est médicaments pour vos problèmes de
sommeil quel qu'il soit dites vous bien
que le rêve c'est le meilleur simulateur
de réalité virtuelle qui existent au
monde
on accède à toute la puissance de calcul
de notre cerveau qui lui contient toutes
les données physiques et toutes les
expériences qu'on a pu vivre au cours de
notre vie on peut tout tester on peut on
peut on peut on peut vraiment je crois
que non
et vous est ce que vous faites des rêves
lucides
est-ce que vous avez des astuces pour
faire vos rêves lucides j'aimerais bien
vraiment que vous mettiez tout ça dans
les commentaires vos expériences par
rapport aux rêves vos astuces par
rapport aux rêves lucides et qu'on fasse
une sorte de base de données dont je
pourrais me servir pour une prochaine
vidéo
merci encore a dream de m'avoir envoyé
leur nouveau bandeau sincèrement c'est
une tueriie bravo à vous mais bravo
aussi à dream pour toutes les données
qu'ils ont pu collecter et l'avancé
qu'ils ont permis de faire au niveau de
la science au niveau du traitement de
l'insomnie
vous pouvez vous abonner si vous
regardez la vidéo que vous n'êtes pas
encore abonné évidemment à ma chaîne
secondaire également ou d'autres vidéos
sort et moi je vous dis à très bientôt
ciao salut salut à toi